- Avec des premiers répondants
qui occupent une place dans la
traditionnelle photo de famille,
un des thèmes du G20 saute
aux yeux : la pandémie
et le partage des vaccins.
L'hôte de la conférence déplore
que dans les pays les plus
pauvres, seulement 3 %
de la population a été vaccinée.
"L'écart avec les pays riches
est moralement inacceptable
et mine la reprise économique",
selon le premier ministre
italien.
Le Canada veut montrer qu'il
fait sa part. Le gouvernement
Trudeau promet dès maintenant
10 millions de doses
supplémentaires et l'équivalent
de 63 millions de doses d'ici
la fin de l'an prochain.
Avec ce qui avait déjà été
promis, la contribution
canadienne s'élève
à l'équivalent de 200 millions
de doses.
CHRYSTIA FREELAND,
vice-première ministre du Canada
- C'est un engagement sincère,
on va le faire.
- Mais encore faut-il qu'elles
se rendent à destination.
Selon un récent rapport d'Oxfam,
une faible proportion des doses
promises à l'échelle mondiale
ont été livrées.
- Je pense qu'on doit constater
qu'on n'a pas la production
chez nous. On ne contrôle pas
la production.
- C'est une première rencontre
du G20 en personne
depuis le début de la pandémie.
L'occasion de renouer
avec des gestes protocolaires,
mais surtout de consolider
des liens avec des pays alliés.
- C'est un grand plaisir
de rencontrer mon ami
Pedro Sanchez, premier minsitre
de l'Espagne.
- Mais il y a un grand absent
à Rome : Xi Jinping.
Le président chinois participe
au G20, mais par vidéo.
La Chine étant, et de loin,
le plus grand pays émetteur
de gaz à effet de serre de la
planète. Cela ne facilite pas
les pourparlers sur le climat
prévus à l'horaire demain.
Ici Madeleine Blais-Morin,
Radio-Canada, Rome.